you know I've learned so much I'm being
real you know I'm gonna say something
that's you know that groundbreaking
something bumping vulnerable I love that
about you Bob okay so I'm gonna be
vulnerable and um I want to say that
because you know in my head I think Eric
Stonestreet at every second right it's
just like just being going to a party
after party I know about this saying in
your own mind when you're driving down
the road and you see a modern family you
know bill apart you know that guy's
killing
congratula-- look great you know I'll
just mumble to myself you know your head
right but deep down right you're you
just think that he is you're living this
you know life but you you do have human
moments well that's the craziest thing I
was just um I forget I was home in
Kansas City and somebody asked me
something what was it that started the
conversation but the point is um and I
told my mom this I said did you hear how
she asked that question like she oh she
said well oh she said how so-and-so
doing how so and so do it and I don't
have to ask about you I know you're
doing great and we got in the car when
we drove away and I said to my mom I
said see that's a that's a interesting
insight you just saw right there because
because of what her perception me which
admitting Lee is is awesome thankful
grateful for financial gain fame TV
whatever all that but that nobody
considers the personal side that life's
complexities still happen you still deal
with scary things vulnerable things
parents health they ask all that stuff
still seeps in
but because I'm on TV and make money
it's like well I know you're doing great
yeah when it's like it's crazy and
here's the thing though it's like the
people say that also like you didn't do
the work though you know like I am being
real um even when we were on man back in
the day we wish to bring you on you know
the audition because you brought heat I
mean I had every commercial that I had
probably lost was given to you back in
that day you know I mean we were four
years you know doing it mm-hmm so when
you when that happened for you it wasn't
like one of those things were like [ __ ]
that guy you know you're like oh yeah
that's a given
that's you know it's like there's a lot
of guys out there like that that if I if
they become a gigantic sitcom star it
would be like a no-brainer
right but still it's like you know you
worked your ass off to get there and and
also I'm learning that we all go through
this thing called life we all have it
but the the truth is it's like uh and
I've told my you know people this before
it's like I'm not getting a ton of
incoming phone calls saying how you
doing today like how are you yeah you
know what I mean and the reason is
because and I kind of think nobody not
that they don't care but because I've
got this visible thing that's clearly
going well yeah I don't maybe have a
tremendous amount of complaining to do
or get to do don't you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I get what you're saying
yeah yeah it's like and then so it all
starts to make sense when you because I
don't consider myself like a Robin
Williams or Chris Farley or guys like
that or you know like people that have
real can go real dark real quick not
that personality but you know you've had
your struggles and a lot of your friends
have had their struggles and you can see
how it can get real serious real quick
when nobody's assuming you can have be
having a bad day because you're so funny
onstage blow me away today I have this
really deep fear of getting wealthy
wealthy mm-hmm and it's because I do
have a propensity for that type of
Darkness that I feel that if I were to
ever have everything I want financially
and I still have that same darkness that
I wouldn't have I wouldn't be able to
explain the pains that I'm going through
like right now you know bills and things
and all of those things I could be like
okay I'm feeling depressed or kind of
blue and I have things to blame it on
mm-hmm what I fear that if I were to
have all of that financially and all I
would have to blame it on is my actual
darkness or demons you're you're so
in the wheelhouse of real thing real
life yeah that's terrifying I had a day
I had his day similar to that yesterday
with this premiere for Secret Life of
pets was yesterday not that I'm gonna
get into this but I just have a lot of
stressful things going on in my life and
yesterday was a super happy awesome day
and for that moment of sustained like
excitement like I'm at a movie premiere
that of a movie that I'm in with Kevin
Hart and Harrison Ford and this is
awesome awesome awesome but when that
ends where do you go back to you go back
right back to that place that is very
normal everyday person which is these
concerns and stresses that you have in
your life right yeah so I think about
that all the time where you know
people's perception of how you're doing
is you can be very much alone in that
world where people aren't checking in
with you a tremendous amount
[Music]